for will crow just a couple of
appearances one start which one four
innings one relief appearance four and
two thirds innings a couple of runs the
3-2
just a little low ball four close call
goes to tommy edmond that's the way our
game begins
hit to left
tom there to make the catch
[Applause]
i don't know if he still would do that
but he can hit
out to reynolds
ballpark holds it
a couple of drives for outs following
edmund's lead off walk
and he's set to work right away
so that laid off walk no big deal but
now the pirates
come to bat here are the first he's been
pounding strikes he's been getting
ground balls he has looked so good and
carlos martinez right a little momentum
heading into this game three against the
pirates just watch carlos on the mound
fly ball
shallow left tyler o'neill comes in to
make the catch you watch him this year
to last year it's just a different guy
the confidence the swagger
and the 02
to carpenter
ground ball and two away
they'll draw the two out free pass
tails back in and a strikeout first of
the afternoon for carlos martinez
that's outside in his second walk that
he's issued
o'neal with a base hit into left field
[Applause]
first two of reach for the cardinals a
walk a single here's harrison boehner
now with two on and one out
and baiter launches one out to deep left
field and his first of the year
it's a three-run homer and it came on a
slider how about that hanging with one
harrison bader hitting career home run
number 32 three-nothing cardinals in the
second inning
and he strikes out dylan carlson
three-run home run for bader gives the
cardinals an early lead
head out to right
nelson was playing him in
and he'd play it off the wall
will have two bases a double
hit it where it's pitch some stallings
showing some power the other way
tom with a ground ball taken there by
tommy edmond that's four ground ball
outs the great willy mcgee and it's
three nothing after two
2-2
and a young lifts it down the left-hand
line and a rocket off the base of the
wall
taken by tom and that'll be a double
with two outs for paul de young on base
for the second time
here's the 2-2
high pop
shallow
center coming in is reynolds and he's
under it and will make the catch through
two and a half
it's the cardinals three pirates nothing
and that's hard hit and throw
will
anchor down at second he did a good job
of avoiding that too
the 2-2
he got him
strikeout number two for martinez
and moran chops it to the right side
out there the turn it's a double play
four six three on the double play
first two reached a strikeout
and then the double play
kisner hit by the pitch so the leadoff
man is on for the cardinals to start the
fourth
there's one
and two a double play
line drive to third todd frazier the
veteran
how many times you said line drive today
all series yeah
he picks martinez apart
[Applause]
nice quick inning for crow now the bucks
bats
broken bat
shallow center and racing in harrison
vader
say you got a package
there's a base hit
two out single to center for eric
gonzalez
oh my goodness
oh no
oh no rafael freitas the head athletic
trainer is out there on that 97 mile per
hour fastball pretty sure the hardest
one he's thrown today
it didn't look like a cotton flush but
it obviously got a piece of him it's
good to see a smile on his face i mean
just a glancing blow i guess this is
remarkable
thank goodness
and you know they're taking every
precaution they wouldn't let him walk
towards first base unless they were
certain that he was going to be okay
[Applause]
and a pitch taken high by carpenter
for walks
one ball two strikes crow delivers and
there's a ground ball to third todd
frazier on to second for the force
halfway mark at pnc park
[Music]
the young
double play
or that
one pitch two outs
that's a fair ball
and that will sneak into the corner
o'neal had to try to play the difference
a double for brian reynolds
the 2-2
ground ball right side taken by
carpenter martinez to the bag
pirates have stranded six we head to the
sixth
it's not like uh he hasn't worked with
men aboard he's gonna work with another
there's a breaking ball
running
todd frazier towards second this ball
hitting the air to right center field
that's carrying but caught by dylan
carlson at the track
a line drive out to right center on to
the seventh
and a strikeout of stallings strikeout
number three for martinez three-nothing
our score the bader home run the only
scoring
in this game that's out in front of the
plate fair ball kisner on it two outs
3-2 pitch got him to reach in a fly ball
that will carry to bader backing up to
make the catch good work by martinez
and that guy is really good giovanni
gallegos but
i love seeing that complete game
starters going deep into right dylan
carlson last time he had eight complete
innings carlos martinez was april of
2018.
ground ball
fair taken by carpenter he'll step on
the bag
in the air out to center
bader near the wall with just enough
room makes the catch so carlos martinez
gets through another inning a one two
three inning in the eighth outstanding
work alex reyes warms up on the mound at
pnc park in pittsburgh as the pirates
come to bat here in the bottom of the
ninth inning the pirates are down to
their last strike carlos martinez goes
eight the two two
he struck him out a one two three for
alex reyes the cardinals
a three nothing win and a sweep in
pittsburgh and st louis
now 16 and 12 on the year